benvenuti sanità story
sapete benissimo che l'edizione di
castori si vuol dire che notte ed è
tardi infatti io ci rifaremo la
challenge tre colori di pennarelli
challenge alle 3 di notte e questa volta
abbiamo nuovi personaggi molto
inquietanti racconteremo anche la
leggenda di questi personaggi o un roi
alla fine del video dovrete iscriverci
qual è il personaggio che vi è piaciuto
più di tutti fra questi personaggi e per
ogni turno ci saranno quattro turni
dovrete votare se vinco io o se vince è
vitale in base a come e colorato e li
dovrete votare nei commenti per il primo
turno vincendo in vitale per il secondo
a ritmo vitale quindi mettetevi comodi
prendete può corre mi raccomando la
state un bel mi piace
questo video questo video raggiunge i 20
mila mi piace faremo un altro episodio
dei tre colori di pennarelli paurosi se
non vi seguite ancora sinistro mandati a
seguirmi nome anita stories se volete
seguitemi anche se tik tok il no è
sempre meter stories vi siete messi
comodi
travolto pitorri
moratti è il primo personaggio 3 2 1
abbiamo per questo è un personaggio
molto
non lo so non so se lo conoscete si
chiama cartoon che quindi gattona
cartone è praticamente all e tubo della
sua storia ed è molto inquietante era un
cartone animato negli anni 30 quindi
intorno al
1936 è stato creato questo cartone
animato di questo gatto molto
inquietante
solo che siccome non stava andando bene
questo cartone animato quindi in pochi
se lo seguivano e non piaceva tanti
forse perché è molto inquietante
quindi è stato cancellato
che cosa è successo da quando è stato
cartella un successo cartone animato
carlton cat che il protagonista che è
questo è diventato una sorta di maggio
cattivo quindi la sua vendetta e rubare
i sogni dei bambini perchè è stato
cancellato questa è la storia che ho
trovato online di questo cartoon cat se
voi sapete qualcos'altro sulla sua
storia scrivete giorni come una teca ten
kate è alto tipo quattro o cinque metri
lunga foltissima qua non si vede ma è
più alto di style
infatti dicono che il peccato che stai a
nel red si scontrassero vincerebbe il
cai turchetto addirittura procediamo a
colorado e speriamo che non ti arrabbi
se lo corriamo su colori e strade
pescare il primo colore abbiamo quel
calderone dei colori
non è bello ma
99 cosa
che come ray questo con sé ma poi non è
il salmone tipo come salmone mi sembra
schema ho preso un pastello a cera
rosa
rosso
sarà bellissimo mischiarli
verde
finisse prima dovrà interrompere l'altra
persona
io ho finito
ferranti notissimo 32
qua e rosso agli occhi rosa i denti
marroni bomba è veramente inquietante è
invece il tuo allora il vino invece
anche lui ai denti marroni con un po di
verde intorno non so se si vede tanto ha
mangiato l'insalata gli è rimasta
incastrata tra i denti sai gli occhioni
rosa da gatto buono e poi quest'ombra
qui che tutto è atto è buono questo non
è proprio un gatto buono ha votate chi
vince il primo turno alito vitale
scrivete nei commenti
secondo turno pronti red 21
niente ancora è un nuovo cattivo che è
uscito insomma di cui si parla
recentemente
praticamente questo cattivo è una sorta
di palo della luce tipo un po umanoide
però è la sua testa sono due sirene e
infatti a bada siren e ed scappa perché
sento il rumore delle sirene perché
infatti se stai venderebbe vicino si
sentono le sirene appunto però in genere
è sempre tipo in nascosto nel bonas
coste in boschi grandissimi e comunque
la leggenda narra anche che faccia
sparire le famiglie intere quindi non si
sa perché questo cattivo serenade
fissato far sparire le famiglie e
soprattutto quelli che campeggiano nel
bosco che fanno del campeggio nel bosco
c'è anche un altro cattivo che gli
somiglia che la fed
fiore
questa è la storia che ho trovato online
di siren ed secondo me è uno dei più
brutti fisica mette veramente
mostruoso ne pensate comunque vediamo
magari con dei colori tipo io faccio
altro famiglia lo rende
ovviamente o iniziamo ora a pescare
rileva il colore
bellissimo
visto col sopra lo zero in camera ma ti
volevo dire tutti i bambini
e questo stupendo non capisca the difeso
bene e questo è ancora più bello questo
forse questo è l'unico bello vediamo un
po ah no pensavo fosse un verde regione
perdiamo blu case blu strano e verde
ovviamente chi mi segue da tanto fate la
validità di veder bird di unità
com'è bello
quindi questo bello multi nega bello per
2 0 questo è un
bene sarà contento sai quello è molto
simile a vediamo syrah una creatura
acquatica
celeste in azzurro giallo davis francia
volo di trend e le
monete farlo tutto verde per renderlo
ancora più presa a
un'interazione vediamo vediamo pronti a
farvi vedere da tre femmine 3
allora vediamo un po il mio siren ed è
giallo fluo e a una parte però arancione
più e poi gli ho fatto la cosa più
importante
gli ho messo lo smalto alle mani
poi l'ho ricoperto di filo spinato così
magari se qualcuno lo incontrerà avrà
una debolezza cioè speriamo che rimanga
impigliato nel filo spinato
vediamo ora cosa di vitale ai dettagli
delle sirene che sono gialle così come
parte del suo corpo e le unghie dei
piedi e delle mani con lo smalto giallo
inizia il secondo turno votate nei
commenti secondo turno vinciani tau
vizio e vitale scrivete nei commenti
fosse ora al terzo ma pronti a rivelare
il flusso persona
molto paura tra gli altri ma fetta mi
divertirò a farlo brutta brutta cosa e
schiarite
seguite da un po il canale sapere perché
abbiamo fatto tanti big lei comunque una
maestra su guerra antipatica cui si
possono fare tanto assistersi qui esce
che ci compete dovrà rivedere come
potrei colorarla allora iniziamo subito
a votare
il tutto non è giallo
speriamo
bene stoner del bruttissimo ok terza
dolore
è un pennarello un po diverso comunque
rosso
perché stai molto bene come principessa
sceso la gente che mi aspetta
merlino dorna glieli guasta bellissimo e
bellissimo
vedendo i colori perché questa volta non
abbia vestito di non ri metterli nelle
calderone male stanno finendo
all ultima stupendo proprio finiamo
per tenere sempre
verde secondo me ci sta si veste ma il
marron
perché proprio di sta bene a scheletro
moltissimo ci sui prati via
aperte come un alieno o celeste
abbiamo fatto entrambi uno scherzo in
casa di denis siamo divertiti da allora
in questa scrittrice lui ho fatto
la faccia verde in pratica è tutta verde
anche se sembra un po sembra un pò fesso
reca
poi a una scopa in mano o un moto ea
dello slam che le case addosso così
impara e in più la scopa di servirà per
pulire lo slime che le case ad hoc la
bellezza è anche i capelli celletti
video che la mia schiettezza che invece
ha un la faccia gialla dall'invidia e la
giacca verde però vi ho messo un
dettaglio non so se si vede questo qui è
una torta si capisce che le sta volando
in faccia
abbiamo di reato la torta in faccia
allora votate chi vince per il terzo
turno quale spiriti servi piazze di più
devo dire che la torta iva devo per me
che mi piace molto come disegno di una
scopa che lo slime che cade anche buona
prova votate nati ultimo zurlo 3 2 1
aiuto per l'ultimo tour abbiamo la
riconosce detto la moglie di chaplin ha
differito
chissà come ne usciranno i capelli con
questo
facciamo un pasticcio perché
un pastello a cera
infine
un pennarello
vediamo
rosso giallo celeste
report prada doppia vita le
persone
pure bello qui ho preso questo è un
pennarello
e questo è un altro pastello
allora abbiamo uno stand a stelo roso
che qui o la viola e arancione ha
caricate farsi i capelli è davvero
noioso mobili faccio è venuto in mente
un'idea che grazie i capelli rossi
praticati the pronti per il gran finale
che bella per
diverte a i capelli viola con i riflessi
arancione vestito arancione poi ho
voluto farle gli occhi un po con questo
ronie natività l'esatto
spaventose e poi gli ho voluto fare
anche le guanciotte rosse fece a vari a
un taglio di capelli molto moderno a le
mèches colorate rosse arancioni sui
resti poi agli occhi celesti guardate
che bel make up che le ho fatto
rosso e la giacca celeste sarò molto
infastidito di questo sicuramente è
quindi chi vince il quarto e ultimo
round quale tiffany vi piace di più
votate ha tra l'altro io avevo il succo
viola che mi è caduto
di votare chi vince l'ultimo turno
noi andremo a vedere i commenti e
vedremo chi ha vinto in base ai vostri
voti ricordatevi di lasciare un mi piace
scriversi sì pure nei commenti quali
altri personaggi volete che oriano la
prossima volta scrive tesi tutto nei
commenti e ora a quattro casi linee su
cui cliccare per vedere i nostri altri
video cliccate su quella che preferite